at the start of the movie we see a
couple being pursued by a local criminal
gang led by the notorious Chang they
make their way into the woods and decide
to hide themselves behind the trees
however their efforts proved to be
futile as the gangsters are able to
locate them easily as a result the
couple is viciously assaulted and killed
by the three gangsters in the next scene
we are introduced to a couple named Yad
and bua who reside in a rural Village
they are deeply in love and devoured to
marry each other when the time comes
however their relationship faces
opposition from yad's family because bua
is a mute girl her family background is
also complicated as her father abandoned
them for another woman nevertheless Yad
Remains undeterred by these
circumstances and is Resolute in his
desire to marry bua on a particular day
Yad and bua are by the nearby River
Gathering crabs for their meal while
returning home with a bucket full of
food a group of local troublemakers
unexpectedly throws a stone at bua and
runs away this causes the innocent girl
to bleed so Yad quickly escorts back
home once there bua's mother tends to
her wounds and asks her to rest for some
time after this she engages in a private
conversation with Yad about his
relationship with bua she advises him to
stop seeing bua saying that he deserves
a better spouse and better in-laws
however Yad firmly asserts that he
disregards the opinions of the villagers
and that his love for bua surpasses all
other considerations despite all these
objections from families and villagers
Yad and bua continue their relationship
they spend a lot of time together in
activities such as fishing cooking and
sharing meals changing two of his
companions also reside Within Village
they seem to have no work to do and as a
result they keep wandering aimlessly
around the village subjecting the
villagers to torment and harassment they
sustain themselves by stealing from the
hard-working residents the leader Chang
has a wife who frequently chastises him
for his irresponsible Behavior but he
pays little attention to it one day as
Yad and buer return after catching some
fish they are intervened by Chang and
his men the gangsters snatched the
bucket filled with Fish And Shang begins
to harass bua yacht attempts to defend
her but the men easily overpower him
fortunately Chang's wife arrives in the
nick of time and breaks up the scuffle
later that evening yad's father as usual
implores Yad to relocate to Bangkok and
find a job there he believes that it is
the only way that they can earn some
money however Yad declines saying he
prefers the Tranquility of the village
over the chaotic City Life the following
morning a dwarf Thug steals a bunch of
bananas from okay let's do this with a
straight face a dwarf Thug steals a
bunch of bananas from a store before
hastily baking his Escape coincidentally
bua passes by the same shop while
carrying bananas in her hands as a
result of this the shopkeeper wrongly
assumes that she's the thief and
subjects her to Rude insults being mute
poor bua is unable to prove her
innocence and starts crying later that
day yad's mother pays a visit to bua's
mother and tells her to keep bua away
from her son because she will never
accept a mute girl as her future
daughter-in-law overhearing their
conversation from a distance bua is left
disheartened after this she makes her
way to the fields and begins crying she
cannot understand why the entire Village
hates her soon after yacht approaches
her and hugs her tightly promising that
he will never leave her side he also
assures her that they will get married
soon later on the couple proceeds to the
river for fishing as Yad busies himself
with adjusting the fishing net Chang and
his gang stealthily arrive at the scene
and abduct they whisk her away to the
woods where Chang forcefully attempts to
undress her bua valiantly tries to fight
back but her resistance only results in
further violence inflicted upon her
meanwhile Yad becomes aware of his
girlfriend's disappearance and upon
searching the surroundings discovers her
abandoned slipper this makes him realize
that boo is in danger so he runs into
the woods and starts calling out her
name shortly after he spots the
gangster's brutally assaulting bua
prompting him to engage in a fierce
brawl against them unfortunately yacht
is of no match and he is easily
overpowered and knocked out after this
Chang forces himself onto the poor girl
and then murders the couple In Cold
Blood the gangsters then bury Yad and
bua in an undisclosed location within
the woods I was not expecting the story
to Chang so abruptly that night bua's
mother anxiously waits for her daughter
to return home however when the night
passes without any sign of her she
decides to visit yad's family hoping
they may have information through her
dismay she discovers that Yad has also
not shown up later the two sets of
parents head out to search for their
missing children when they reach the
fields they stumble upon the belongings
left behind by yadenbua further
intensifying their worries soon after
they receive information from a villager
who informs them that Chang and his gang
were pursuing the couple the previous
day with this knowledge the parents
confront Chang at his place but as
expected the notorious gang leader
threatens them and sends them away
finding themselves at a loss The
Grieving parents decide to report their
children is missing at the local police
station even expressing their suspicion
towards Chang's gang however the police
insist on concrete evidence before
entertaining any suspicions moreover the
head officer speculates that the couple
may have chosen to leave for bigger
cities to start a new life together cops
really just gonna make [__] up like that
in the next scene we are introduced to a
member of Chang's gang lack he is
roaming alone in the Woods burdened by
guilt and unable to escape the weight of
their heinous actions shortly after
Chang and another gang member named Fett
approach him asking if he is all right
Leck confesses that he is feeling like
crap these days and even suggests
turning themselves in hearing this an
enraged Chang brings out his gun and
points it at lack he says that will
shoot him if the police find out about
their deeds following this the trio
heads deep into the woods for a Hunting
Expedition as they try to find some
animals surprisingly they are haunted by
Buu's spirit this forces the gangsters
to run away from the woods as soon as
they can that same night they are seen
enjoying with some girls indulging in
drinks and narcotics in the midst of
their activities like excuses himself to
take a leak as he begins the process he
unexpectedly notices a girl dressed in
white lying on the ground black slowly
approaches her and turns her over only
to discover that it is bua this
terrifies him so he quickly retreats to
his friends after winding up their
Gathering the gangsters return to their
respective houses only to be plagued by
haunting visions of bua lek in
particular goes to his bed but continues
to see bua's spiritual form seemingly on
the verge of attacking him this
nightmarish ordeal deprives him of sleep
throughout the night in the morning Leck
confides in fat Sharing The Haunting
experiences he has endured to his
surprise Fett reveals that he is also in
similar Visions like proposes that they
depart from the village and seek
employment in larger cities he also
points out that they will be doomed if
the villagers find out about their deeds
however Fett urges practical thinking
saying it will be impossible for people
like them to find jobs huh poor guys
afterwards the trio is once again seen
in the forest engaging in hunting
activities this time Lex visions of bua
intensify compelling him to flee for his
life while running away he is suddenly
struck on the head hard with a wooden
Branch resulting in his death later that
night fat two Falls victim to a
Relentless nightmare that deprives him
of sleep seeking Solace he retreats to
the restroom to freshen up only to be
haunted by the spirit of Yad fearing
that he will also get killed fet visits
a nearby Temple early the very next
morning and offers prayers for his
preservation after this he meets with
Chang and resolves to confess their
crime to the villagers but once again
the gang leader becomes angry and
punches fet in the face commanding him
to remain silent when the latter still
keeps on insisting Chang beats him up
viciously that night Chang endures a
chilling dream in which she is bound to
his bed tormented by the ghosts of Yad
and bua who approach him menacingly with
an ax the following day as fed is
fishing at a nearby River he is startled
by a haunting sound he looks around but
finds no one in sight suddenly a splash
in the water startles him further
terrified fat attempts to flee but he is
caught by someone from behind and
forcefully submerged underwater the
unfortunate deaths of lack and fat
Phil's Chang's father with concern so he
urges Chang to confess his bad Deeds
warning him of a similar fate if he
fails to do so however Chang refuses to
acknowledge any wrongdoing fearing that
he will be imprisoned unbeknownst to
Chang the vengeful spirits of Yad and
bua are closing in on him during the
night Chang is sleeping beside his wife
when he hears a sound coming from the
kitchen startled he wakes his wife
asking if she heard the sound too
however she scolds him for disturbing
her sleep and goes back to bed soon
after Chang hears the same sounds once
more instilling a sense of dread within
him he gets up to switch on the lights
only to discover that the tube light is
malfunctioning gripped by fear of the
dark he attempts to light a candle but
it mysteriously extinguishes itself just
then the spirit of bua materializes
before him scaring the life out of him
in response Chang hastily grabs a knife
and repeatedly stabs the ghostly figure
however he soon realizes that he has
stabbed his own wife resulting in her
death Chan cannot believe what he has
done and starts crying like a baby right
then an unidentified figure appears
behind him and Strikes him unconscious
after a while Chang regains his senses
and finds himself restrained to his
astonishment Yad and bua appear in front
of him both seemingly alive here the
truth is finally revealed shortly after
the gangsters had buried the couple the
rain poured down causing them to regain
their Consciousness from their lifeless
State then despite their injuries they
somehow managed to free themselves from
the suffocating mod supporting one
another they tended to their wounds and
took shelter in the forest for several
days slowly but surely they recuperated
fueled by an unwavering determination to
seek Vengeance for the evil Deeds
committed against them believing that it
will take evil to destroy evil they
begin to haunt their tormentors to the
worst extent possible and then killed
them one after another hearing their
Revelation Chang pleads for his life
resembling The Plea once uttered by bua
in the past however with the tables now
turned in the couple's favor they
disregard his pleas and finish him off
finally completing their Revenge please
tell me there's a post-credits scene
about the banana dwarf Thief subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching